hey guys tim ferriss here before we jump
into this episode I'm gonna do something
I very rarely do and that is to make a
direct ask with hat in hand my brand new
book just came out today it is called
tribe of mentors subtitle short life
advice from the best in the world
if you like the podcast you will love
this book
I reached out to a hundred and thirty
people who are the best at what they do
in sports investing business acting
directing you name it we got it
cryptocurrency done and it turned out
better than I ever could have expected
many of my friends think of all my books
it is the easiest to read the easiest to
use so check it out please take a look I
put out so much free material the
podcast is free the 700-plus blog posts
are free every once in a while I put out
something like this and it's not that
expensive so please take a look
tribe of mentors dot-com and it does
make a great holiday gift or gift for
others there's something for everybody
in here it is really a
choose-your-own-adventure guide a buffet
of options for improving your life both
in business and in the personal sphere
so take a look I appreciate you taking a
look tribe of mentors calm or anywhere
that books are sold at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking and I all
see the poster question
I must - Nettie Morgan is a living
tissue over metal ZOA this episode is
brought to you by me undies
I've spent the last few years wearing
underwear from these guys 24/7 or close
to it outside of showers and sexy time
and swimming and they are the most
comfortable and colorful underwear I've
ever owned you should check out the
camouflage boxer briefs I'm a big fan me
undies are designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro mowed ow
what's that it is a fabric three times
softer than cotton trust me try it out
you'll understand why I wear these so
much
if underwear isn't your thing though I
would imagine everyone wears underwear
but if it isn't your thing munities also
makes socks their socks are spun from
premium material making them just as
comfortable as the underwear now right
now the undies has an exclusive offer
just for tim ferriss show listeners you
can get 20% off your first order and
free shipping so check it out take a
look some of them are pretty rad
they have different cereals from your
childhood on underwear and a lot more me
undies com forward slash Tim take a look
my undies comm forward slash Tim they
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee if
you're unhappy with your purchase for
any reason just send them back and you
receive a full refund again that's me
undies comm forward slash Tim for 20%
off and free shipping
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
of this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I ended
up meeting with the CEO not very long
ago why are they so popular well they
are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of entrepreneurs and
beyond you can take pictures of receipts
you can link your credit card and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier and also in fact
I recommend a PDF they didn't ask me to
read this part by the way they put
together PDF a while back called
breaking the time barrier subtitle how
to unlock your true earning potential so
you can search for breaking the time
barrier a lot of people ask me how can I
get a 4-hour workweek with a service
business and the story in that ebook its
PDF is the short answer it's really
really good so I think you should also
check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books calm forward-slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy
why hello ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show or it is my job
each and every episode to deconstruct
world-class performers from every
possible domain whether we are talking
about entertainment military athletics
business or in this case something a
little bit different to tease out the
habits maybe routines maybe techniques
definitely that you can use and apply in
your own life now the subject matter and
interviewee in this episode I suppose
could be introduced at least should be
introduced I think with a quote and that
is quote those who are easily shocked
should be shocked more often that is by
Mae West so if you find yourself getting
a little offended or find yourself
recoiling or leaning forward with great
interest and enthusiasm notice that
notice all of those things this is an
unusual interview and it came about
because I was walking through Dallas
Airport I want to say at one point to
catch a connecting flight and I got a
text from a friend and the text said Tim
exclamation point exclamation point hope
all's well with you I have an
interesting guest you might consider for
the show
Alice little top earning courtesan for
the bunnyranch long backstory on how I
know her but seven figure earners super
smart who definitely be out of left
field let me know if I can make the
intro now for those of you who don't
know the bunny ranch is a legal brothel
in Nevada so I received this text from
Rob wolf yes that's right our OBB last
name wolf wo LF Rothschild and I will
there Rob explained well he knows Alice
some other time but I get this text so
of course I say yes yes yes is she good
conversations your 210 how good at
storytelling is she
and one thing led to another and then
boom I was connected with Alice so Alice
little on Twitter at the Alice little is
considered the number one top running
legal sex worker in the United States
she is a four foot eight hence Alice
little legal sex worker at Nevada's
world-famous Moonlite bunnyranch and
there are a number of associated
brothels within that family but we won't
get into that this episode is in case
you haven't picked it up already
definitely not suitable for work people
not suitable for work NSFW can't imagine
you be listening to this on speakers at
work but just in case you have no common
sense there you go and in this
wide-ranging conversation we cover quite
a lot including technical sex tips how
Alice puts people at ease including
adult virgins and apologize apologize
apologize my apologies for the crunching
in the background that is my dog Molly
chomping on a bully stick otherwise
known as bull pizzle otherwise known as
bull penis so may be very appropriate
for this episode okay back on track
focus Ferris we talked about BDSM if you
don't know what that is well define it
and power play we talked about threesome
do's and don'ts plus what she calls the
big ko finishing move misconceptions
about sex workers and the realities why
what she calls the girlfriend experience
GFE is her most popular offering how she
works with couples who want to explore
new boundaries new worlds and much more
alice is also a vocal advocate for legal
sex workers and the founder of the
political movement hookers for health
care a lot of back story there she's
been featured on ABC's Nightline and is
no stranger to the conversation of what
is called sex surrogacy that we get into
a little bit and seeks to shift
America's perceptions of sex workers and
sex work so there you have it you can
check her out at the Alice little calm
and elsewhere I hope you enjoyed this
very unusual but very very
practical conversation as much as I did
so without further ado here is Alice
little Alice welcome to the show Hey how
are you thanks so much for having me
I am fantastic and I am well caffeinated
I've been looking forward to this
conversation all day and if wanted to
have this conversation or some form of
it for many years because I want to say
ten years ago after reading The
Alchemist by Paulo Coelho which is sold
a hundred million plus copies around the
world oddly enough he ended up peering
in my last book but that's a digression
I was in an airport and I picked up
another book of his without really
knowing anything about it and it was
called eleven minutes which is very very
different from his other books and it is
a novel about the experiences of a young
Brazilian sex worker in her journey to
self-realization through sexual
experience and it takes her around the
world to Geneva in all these different
locations and describes her lessons and
experiences in hardship but also peak
emotional experiences and so on and I
remember thinking to myself after
finishing that what a unique life and at
some point in my life would be amazing
to sit down and have a conversation with
someone in that world and here we are so
thank you for making the time absolutely
I'm really excited looking forward to
this we're gonna have some fun and on
the book point I was looking through
these bullets and I have so many
questions for you but one of the bullets
was antiquarian rare book collector and
I thought we would just start there for
no good reason other than I'm curious do
you how did you get into that first of
all and do you have any particular
favorites that come to mind yes rare
book collecting almost came naturally to
me
my family has had a lot of heirlooms and
antiques and a number of those include
older familiar Bibles that just kind of
sparked my interest from a young age and
then as I've grown my interests have
diversified and I started looking into
other types of publications that existed
within that time period I've always been
attracted to things like leather bound
books in the history of a book that is
aged and has had ownership that there
might be perhaps pencil marks in there
or notes from the person who first owned
it kind of putting their thumbprint on
that piece of history and so I kind of
think of those books is not just a piece
of historical literature but also a
piece of historical evidence oftentimes
as to how it relates to a particular
person mm-hmm right no absolutely it's
that's one of my favorite thing one of
my favorite things about used books is
is in in some cases looking at the
highlights and discovering what someone
else thought was important in those
pages and you were you mentioned your
family you were born in Dublin is that
correct yes just outside of Dublin
proper all right which might partially
at least explain the natural red hair
for which you have known among other
things and move to the US as I
understand it around age five and how
did you ultimately then find your way to
sex work do you remember your first
exposure or how that came to be I would
love to know the story which I don't
know and I had both myself and someone
else trying to do background research
and part of what made me even more
excited to have the conversation is
there's not a whole lot I mean there's a
little bit but there's not much so I
feel like this is very fresh at least
for me so how did you find your way to
sex work how did that happen
growing up I had always been a very
naturally curious child I would be the
kid that asked one too many questions
that had a little bit too much to say
that always wanted to know more whatever
it was that I wasn't supposed to know at
that age that's what I was most
interested in for example I remember
being a fourth grader and trying to
check out the Diary of Anne Frank and
being told it was grossly inappropriate
and going so far as to have my parents
take it to the school board and petition
for me to be allowed to read this book
so as far as being in I guess connection
to my body and my sexuality as I
progress through my years it came very
naturally to me to be sexually
inquisitive I asked questions such as
why is the model monogamy why are we
limiting ourselves to man and wife what
about other options what other paradigms
are there what what more is there to
discover and learn from this and that
led me to discovering the cathouse
series which featured the Moonlite
bunnyranch
on HBO that aired for a number of years
it was incredibly impactful and it
really kind of was the first sexual
Renaissance at least in modern society
that we have had I watched that show
growing up and I just admired the free
sexual attitude that they had and the
energy that they had were there any
particular episodes or scenes or
anything like that that stuck in your
mind in particular and where were you
when you were watching this where were
you living oh goodness I was actually
living on Long Island in New York at the
time and it would be way way late at
night nothing against Long Island I grew
up in Long Island which part of Long
Island oh my gosh are you serious I grew
up in Nassau County oh yeah I was I was
a Suffolk boy myself but I spent a lot
of time in Nassau as well okay all right
strong Island reunion unexpected I like
it so you're watching this series are
there any particular moments or scenes
or characters or really stuck out to you
prominently featured women on the show
and she captured me everything from the
way that she carried herself to the
language she used when talking about her
job and the relationships that she had
with clients and she was willing to show
things that many people oftentimes
didn't consider such as couples being at
the ranch or BDSM being an option she's
even had an episode specifically showing
Pony play before which is when somebody
is hooked up to a cart and at
pull somebody around acting as if they
are a human Pony
I was gonna ask wasn't sure if what
variety of Pony play we were pretty
fantastic stuff I just really loved that
free ability to explore and innovate in
this sexual way and it really spoke to
me I was at the time a BDSM educator and
still AM to this day I travel around the
country I presented all sorts of
different events and panels and could
you could you
sorry to interrupt a cute define for
people and I think we'll probably stop a
few times in this conversation to do
this
BDSM having lived in the Bay Area I've
since moved but in the area for 17 years
and having taken tours of the armory and
so on I am am familiar with BDSM or what
it is at least yeah it's a wild spot and
for those people wondering you can look
it up the armory they buy 50 gallon
drums of lubrication
at a time which apparently you can get
on Amazon Prime which I can't imagine is
a net gain for Amazon but I'm going off
the rails
so BDSM what is BDSM there are multiple
different ways to define BDSM but simply
put it's an acronym that can stand for
several different things
anything from bondage discipline
sadomasochism to sometimes it's been
used to describe say bondage discipline
dominance and Submission so the exact
word egde in the exact verbage changes
depending on the circles there's not
100% agreement as to which letter has
which particular meeting but generally
speaking it's divided up into BD for
bondage and discipline d s for dominance
and Submission and SM for sadism and
masochism what of all of those what I
think many of those are somewhat
self-evident or people can envision what
they mean what is discipline
what does that mean discipline in the
car
texts of BDSM is the exchange of a
physical or emotional control over
someone where you are either say
spanking them or perhaps going so far as
to verbally chastise them if that's the
agreed-upon dynamic it's set up to kind
of recreate that structure often found
within the military where there's this
chain of command in this understanding
of who reports to him within the BDSM
culture sometimes that discipline will
enter into a submissive dominant
relationship where that's used in
combination with their relationship and
it makes me think of and I don't think
this quote applies everywhere but I want
to say Mae West but Mae West is kind of
like the female version of Mark Twain
you can kind of attribute any quote to
her so I may be getting the attribution
wrong but the quote I don't think she'd
mind either the the quote was something
along the lines of everything in life is
about sex except for sex sex is about
power and at least in the BDSM world I
imagine that would have some application
but the BDSM then it sounds like based
on what you said your fascination with
that or even teaching that predated your
work as a sex worker is that right yes I
celebrated my 18th birthday by going
into a dungeon space in New York City
for the first time and finally getting
to interact with this community that I
had been waiting to for a number of
years
my interest in BDSM started very
organically in high school things like
tying up my first girlfriend with rope
and kind of enjoying that and it led me
to discover the BDSM community and from
there I was just chomping at the bit to
get that education and that knowledge
and when did the then when did the or
how really did the sex work enter the
picture there's a very fine line between
BDSM and sex work in the sense that both
are very sexually charged activities it
it was very comfortable and easy almost
for me to make the jump from one to the
other it was a very conscious decision
where I sat down one day and said to
myself where do I see myself going
within the next year where do I see
myself going the year after that what
about five years and when I really sat
and thought about it I saw myself
entering a profession that allowed me to
connect with people on a intimate level
more so than what society generally
allows for in the past I've worked as a
massage therapist so I got to develop
that hands-on relationship with the
clientele but it kind of just fell short
of that deep personal intimacy that I
was looking forward to I've always felt
that life is about enrichment both for
our own betterment as well as the
betterment of those around us and for me
sex work ended up being the perfect
channel to do that now you've done a
number of other things you mentioned
massage therapists and please correct me
if I'm wrong because of course you
should everyone should be cautious about
believing everything they read on the
internet but I have emergency medical
technician jockey
at racetracks those are other things
that you tried correct oh yes I have
tried a little bit of everything under
the Sun trying to find something that
just felt right I wanted to find a job
where not only did I feel comfortable
with what I was doing but I also felt a
more meaningful calling than it just
being a job but it actually had a deeper
purpose to it that kind of relates back
to that book you mentioned eleven
minutes where she goes through the
sexual journey and kind of finds herself
it very is true for many of us sex
workers that message of self-discovery
and sexual freedom and that ability to
explore those parts of ourselves and
share them with what our formerly
strangers is incredible what was your
first or what you would consider your
first gig I suppose I'm gonna stumble a
little bit because I'm not I'm not sure
which labels are words to use so if I
offend please forgive but what was your
first I guess client engagement as a sex
worker do you remember your first
experience and could you describe it for
us or one of the first I remember it
very very crystal clear the bunnyranch
maintains a set of forums online which
allows for greater depth of
communication and intimacy before we
even meet face-to-face it allows the
ladies like myself to post photos
different interests kind of share about
us on that humanistic level rather than
just that appearance level I had posted
about a particular interest I had in one
of these specialty rooms at the ranch
I'd simply said hey I'm something I'm
really looking forward to trying I'd
love somebody to come out and spend that
time with me and within the week I had
an email and it was my first appointment
I'm sorry what was the room maybe you'll
get to it but I'm just so curious it is
this setup where it's an indoor Jacuzzi
with an attached Suites next to it this
way you can come and go between the
jacuzzi and the bed as comfortably as
you so please got it okay please
continue sorry so you so you received an
email from a client yeah and they're
like I love this idea you have I'm
interested let's do it so of course I
have all the nerves and anxiety that
comes with the first appointment in a
new industry and everything ended up
going as smooth as clockwork it was just
so much simpler than my mind made it out
to be I tend to overthink and
overanalyze things and so I naturally
always prepare for the worst in any
scenario what happens if I make a
mistake what if we don't connect what if
something happens in the jacuzzi breaks
I tried always plan for such
contingencies and at the end of the day
the reality was is the intimacy just
very natural and comfortable and to this
day that client is still one of my
regulars that I get to see and connect
with fairly often
all right so you mentioned you're
nervous highly analytical by nature and
then it went like clockwork what is the
format of one of those first encounters
and what I mean by that is I've read
that and I actually don't know where
this term comes in but I've read about
negotiations so it seems like you get
paired with a big sister and then
there's a sit-down with the client is
there a negotiation today did I miss
read that and what role does the big
sister play or the the more experienced
woman well to start with I'd kind of
like to describe what it's like when you
come into the ranch because I kind of
helped set this stage for what an
experience there is like sure either
either somebody would set an appointment
with a particular lady or they would
come in and request a lineup if you
choose to request a lineup all of the
available ladies will come out to the
parlor we stand in the line introduce
ourselves and after we introduce
ourselves you're free to walk up to the
lady of your choice take her by the hand
and go for a tour of the property the
bunny ranch is an incredibly historic
property it's been there since the 1950s
it's beautiful and has been many times
remodeled revamped and renovated so it
really is a top-of-the-line gorgeous
facility so we like to kind of showcase
that in addition to some of the
different specialty rooms suites and
offerings that we happen to have at the
ranch after the tour the guests and the
lady then go back to that ladies room
where they will then sit and have a
negotiation if the lady is new for the
first couple of times they'll introduce
the big sister or a mentor who's an
older more experienced lady that's been
there for a little bit to kind of help
you through those first couple times
until you start to feel comfortable and
more confident during the negotiation
that's where we kind of have a
conversation I hate to use the word
negotiation because it feels very
business I like to think of it more like
having a conversation with a friend it's
something that happens very organically
it gives me the opportunity to get to
know who you are on that personal level
and also
kind of you know a little bit about
myself when it comes to intimacy and
attraction it's so much more than just
that skin level it certainly goes deeper
so I really like to take that time
during that first few moments to really
get to know who somebody is as a person
beyond they're at a brothel they're
interested in services I like to take a
little bit longer than most in that
particular regard during the negotiation
we'll also talk about what particular
activities were interested in what sorts
of fantasies they may have what sort of
special requests that they would have
and from there we kind of formulate what
our time together is going to look and
feel like how long would be like to
spend together would we like to stay in
my room or are we interested in one of
those specialty suites I mentioned
earlier is there a particular activity
that they want to try or is there a
second lady they would like to involve
in the encounter that's kind of where we
get to shape and figure out what we're
going to do and after that point you
would then go to the office they handle
all the financial transactions very
discreetly the ladies don't actually
have any interaction with the clients
personal information for their
protection all of that is handled by the
cashier we didn't get a set of sheets
couple towels perhaps a bottle of
champagne for fun and head back to my
room where the Sweden we're off on an
adventure I want to dig into a few
follow-up questions so you sit down and
I think in my mind I'm envisioning I've
only seen the first installment of the
film Fifty Shades of Grey where they're
having this conversation about what are
the the go no-go rules
I suppose which among my friends who do
BDSM of course is very orinsa on some
level seems very familiar what are the
what are some of the questions that you
like to ask or the most important
questions that you ask I tend to work
with a very wide variety of people and
more often than not I work with people
that I've had the opportunity to commune
Kait with the via email that's given me
the opportunity to kind of get to know
them in their personality a little bit
so I'm able to better adjust the types
of questions I ask for example if I have
a couple that has never had a third
person involved in any sort of sexual
encounter the very first thing I'm going
to ask is what are you comfortable with
what are you not comfortable with and
allow them to start setting their own
particular boundaries because with a
couple you certainly don't want to
violate any sort of pre-existing
communication agreements that they have
made and so I like to pay an honor
almost to their relationship and kind of
allow them to dictate in a way to me
where they see me fitting into the
puzzle of their pre-existing connection
versus what if sorry not to interrupt
but I'll prior interrupt a lot so let's
say a couple comes to you and as you
noted perhaps they've never had this
experience and so you ask them what
they're comfortable with and they're not
sure and they ask you what would you
suggest as guidelines or how should we
do this we've never done this before
we're not sure what would make us
comfortable or uncomfortable what types
of guidelines might you offer them or
suggestions the very first thing that I
like to start with is a very simple and
really fun getting to know you exercise
of course dig into a little bit more of
an adult level I find that here and this
is an adult show so we can get into the
details it's okay oh fantastic here we
go yeah for those parents in the car
with their kids right now I'd recommend
ear muffs or having a pause break for
birds and the bees conversation and
we're back so please continue yeah so
people are looking for suggestions from
you as a couple what do you do and you
mentioned an exercise yes the very first
thing I like to start with is a foreplay
exercise women take significantly longer
to become aroused than men that's a
biological fact and often times and
sexual encounters there's not enough of
that warmup period especially during a
get-to-know-you that first encounter
with somebody that time needs to be even
moreso explored and even more so
embraced and so I like to simply start
by the two of us either myself and the
wife or myself and the husband
undressing one of the partners very very
slowly and sensually while they have
their eyes closed this does a couple of
different things first when you close
your eyes during any sort of intimate
encounter it's going tight in all of
your other senses your sense of smell
becomes significantly sharper where
you're able to smell a hint of perfume
or that whiff of Cologne when you close
your eyes you feel every single touch of
the fingertip the pressure of the nails
sliding over your backer over your
partner's nipples it's incredibly
arousing and just that one simple thing
adds a certain depth and really lets you
sink into what's happening and
appreciate every single movement I kind
of like to think of sex as a dance in a
way it's working with a partner or
partners you're coordinating your
movements and your energy your breathing
oftentimes will become subconsciously
synchronized and you just naturally fall
into this flow where you're exploring
kissing touching and just embracing and
letting things really naturally go with
the flow and letting your mind kind of
take over instinctually rather than
pre-programming and deciding first I
shall remove the top then I shall slowly
remove this bra but with my teeth that
that removes all the sexual spontaneity
out of it there has to be that certain
organic element to it otherwise you're
looking at a porn not a true encounter
okay see you get see you get that you
slowly undress one of the partners then
then what happens then we go to each of
the other two in turn either myself or
the husband first
whichever things just happened to come
naturally same process repeated over
again and at this point I'm going to
start encouraging them to not just
explore each other's bodies but also
explore their body or also explore my
body as well so I might take his hand
and kiss his fingertips and litter
holding his hand trace it down my neck
and press it onto my breast this way he
feels comfortable and that touch barrier
has been breached once that's happened
I've have found that naturally people
settle in a little bit more and they
start to give themselves permission to
enjoy that encounter and really oh
that's really happening now oh I can do
these things I do have the power of the
sexual expression and freedom here so in
that circumstance when you look over
your experiences with couples what did
this this is gonna set might sound funny
but what are the smarter guys do and
what do the not-so-smart guys do and the
reason I ask is that I recall a
conversation I had with a dear friend of
mine who for a period of time he's
happily married with with kids now and
has has voluntarily chosen monogamy but
back in his sort of peak athletic years
he was a master of threesomes and I mean
really just seemed to have near magical
powers and he said he said to me at one
point he he observed that if you have if
you want to have threesomes with say a
girlfriend or a wife he said rule number
one is you do not penetrate the other
woman on the first date
and he said if you do that you can have
many many many threesomes but if you
penetrate the other woman
ie not your girlfriend on that first
encounter you could completely shut her
down
meaning your girlfriend and then you've
just you've just ruined your opportunity
to have an ongoing enjoyable experience
as as as a couple so I don't know if
that's true
sounds like it's plausible but are there
what are certain things that smart guys
do versus not so smart guys or
experienced guys in that type of
circumstance so the smart guys
communicate they're very clear with
their significant other as to what their
desire is what kind of fantasies they
want to see and what kind of an
experience they want to have they also
have to be willing to
wait until their partner is comfortable
and ready to have that experience trying
to manipulate your partner into its
sexual encounter is the absolute worst
thing that you could do and that is
typically the first thing that I see
couples do when they're doing it the
wrong way if the guy is doing it for
very selfish reasons where you know he
doesn't really care if his wife's into
it this is all about him those guys
they're not being respectful of the
woman's right over her own body let
alone their agreed upon relationship so
I would say that the very very first
thing is communication
followed by consent and how do you help
to break the ice if let's say you you've
removed the clothing you've traced
someone's hand maybe both the let's just
assume for the time being man and a
woman so both of their hands on your
bodies if they're still not sure what to
do what what is a good next move if
you're directing things if I'm kind of
playing ringleader as it was and we're
still reaching this point where we're a
little bit tentative and that intimacy
hasn't quite clicked into place the next
thing will often go ahead is move on to
but it's called an edible body massage
this is where you use body safe products
that also are either flavored and
scented for example a honey massage
lotion and then we'll go ahead and lay
one or both of the partners down and
slowly use that and warm them up that
way again keeping with that touch
keeping with that sensory input and
really allowing everyone to participate
this isn't a scenario where one partner
is on the other side of the bed this is
a scenario where both myself and the
wife may be massaging the husband or
they must be massaging me either which
way it just allows for that continuation
and natural flow of energy and chemistry
what are other things that that you do
in those circumstances to make the woman
come
people are there any other particular
tricks of the trade or phrases or
questions or guidelines that you use
this is gonna be an interesting one but
since this is an adult show one of the
things I like to do to help make the
woman relax a little bit more is I like
to make her have an orgasm this can
either be through digital stimulation
with my fingers or perhaps with the sex
toy perhaps with the assistance of her
partner playing with her nipples or
kissing her allowing the woman to go
ahead and have that first orgasm in that
threesome it makes her feel secure that
she's not going to be a less than
partner many women have this concern
about this comparison between themselves
and the other women I think it's one of
the reasons why I have so many couples
is because being a 4 foot 8 petite
redhead there's not a lot of women who
can look at themselves and feel compared
to me the body type the height it's such
a complete night and day difference that
they feel comfortable sharing their
significant other with me because they
don't see me as a threat to their
relationship and then when we go ahead
and give that woman the first orgasm
it's solidifying her place within that
sexual dynamic saying yes your feelings
your sexual experience is absolutely
important and it's going to be a part of
this women are lucky we get to come more
than once and so why not start things
off with a bang why not indeed what are
some of your best practices for helping
a woman to orgasm give any favorite sex
toys do you have any many women have
difficulty orgasmic or may-maybe coming
into an experience perhaps not with your
clients I don't know but in orgasmic
right they haven't experienced that
before what are what are some of the
approaches or or sort of technical tips
or toys that you use that you've found
to be particularly helpful sure thing I
happen to work with
both couples as well as single women
many times over this particular problem
and believe it or not it's a societal
endemic problem where the majority of
women have trouble reaching climax
either single by themselves or with a
partner so I think talking about
something like this is really important
personally I always love to suggest the
simplest toy which is a wall plug in
Hitachi Magic Wand such a great device
great device it is the best and as far
as sex safety goes between partners
always make sure you're putting a condom
over the top of the Hitachi because we
want to play safe with our toys so when
we're going ahead and using the Hitachi
that is absolutely fantastic for direct
clitoral stimulation you can go ahead
and an increase or decrease the
intensity by pushing down harder or
softer and if that still isn't quite
doing it the second thing I like to do
is a simple one or two finger insertion
nothing too much more than that
especially on the first orgasm because
that's kind of a a warm-up
we're like diesel engines it takes us a
moment to get warmed up but once we're
there we're gonna stay purring for a
while and so you're doing the one or two
finger insertion along with the Hitachi
Magic Wand yep but just same slow
repetitive motion in and out and the
whole thing that a lot of guys make the
mistake on when trying to help their
partner climax is variation in my
experience most women actually perform a
more rhythmic approach into at a simple
one-to-one to in-out in-out tends to
work a lot better than one two one two
one two and out and out like god it's
very difficult for a woman to achieve
climax that way and that's just a
biological difference between men and
women
I've noticed that men tend to like
variation when powering themselves or
receiving a [ __ ] for a woman they
like the difference in strokes length
and pressure worse well never pretty
consistent about what we like we like to
do what we do and stick with that so
it's okay if you're doing the same thing
over and over again if it's working
trust me
y'all know so a couple a couple of notes
on the Hitachi Magic Wand for people a
is you can certainly find it at just
about any sex shop you can certainly buy
it also online Amazon etc and it can
serve double duty for those of you who
might have read tools of titans for
relaxing hyper tonic or spasmed muscles
so for instance in the forearms in the
forearm flexors and so on if you've
really tight forearms gymnasts in fact
former national team men's coach coach
summer Somm er recommended the Hitachi
Magic Wand but not for sex for relieving
muscle tightness so if you need that
excuse guys you can grab one of those
and then your girlfriend will steal it
from you but but that's that's one do
you use the high or the low setting what
most often I'm kind of a low setting
girl I kind of just prefer that that
lower intensity level and I kind of will
save that higher mode for more of the
very end of the session if we really
want to ramp things up and well I guess
the best way to describe it is that the
head touch he has two settings strong
and crawling up the walls strong and how
long is let's just say in the case of
the couple like a a minimum or an ideal
length of session how much time do you
have it completely berries from couple
to couple generally speaking for
somebody's first encounter I like to go
ahead and include something called an
out date what an out date is is that it
actually allows us to leave the brothel
and then travel anywhere we would like
in Nevada so perhaps we all go out for
lunch first this way we get to have some
conversation get to have a little bit of
that mental stimulating for a plane not
just the physical stimulating for a play
then after lunch we'll head back to the
branch and from there go ahead and kind
of enjoy our sexual offense divot ease
couples that are on say a traveling time
schedule
they only have a couple of hours it's
absolutely okay to spend just two hours
with Sunday or even just a single hour
with someone but generally speaking for
couples I recommend going ahead and
investing in a slightly more elaborate
experience especially for their first
time because that attitude and that
energy is going to make a huge
difference in regards to what you
experience here at the ranch with me
that little bit of extra connection time
of just going and having a simple meal
with someone it gives all the stress a
moment to leave your body it allows all
of your anxiety to kind of go away and
dissipate and by the time we make it
back to the bedroom
you've already relaxed the butterflies
to have calmed down and you feel a
little bit more comfortable with where
things are going next what are some of
the most requested activities you
mentioned activities a few times what
are what are if you were looking at the
pie chart of requests that you've
received what are the most often
requested activities I would say that
there are two different things that
would kind of fall into that pie chart
it would probably be more accurate to go
ahead and label it is both experiences
and specific activity requests and
sometimes those things go hand in hand
or they go separately probably my most
requested experience is something called
the girlfriend experience it's where we
take things to that next level of
intimacy and I often times it's argued
it could even border on sexual surrogacy
where you're taking things that next
step further that's where we're going
out to eat together we may choose to go
to a concert together we're going to
keep in touch in communication between
our time together via text or email or
perhaps phone calls it allows for that
depth and that building of relationship
that really transcends beyond just a
single standalone session absolutely the
majority of my couples and the majority
of my clients in general tend to fall
into that more girlfriend experience
category the second most requested
experience is kink or bee
and fetish activities this may be in the
example of a couple a couple that is
interested in bondage and discipline
where I might teach the husband the safe
way to use rope to tie up his wife and
then explore how to use floggers and sex
toys to give her that sexual release
whereas say with a single male he may be
interested in having me dominate him
instead and he wants to explore his
submissive side and his submissive
energy so I'd say that would probably be
the most second requested category I
have and the third would probably be two
girl encounters having a threesome is on
almost every single guy's bucket list
and there's no better place in the world
than the bunny ranch to get to have that
encounter we're professionals we I mean
we'll take care of you the right way all
right so these those sound like the
experiences if we were getting into
specifics are there any more so the
specific sex acts themselves
yeah with within any of those buckets
I'm just so curious to know because I
remember having a conversation living in
San Francisco for a long time getting to
know people are very sex positive and
support sex workers and one of them said
for instance that they found like oral
sex [ __ ] to be very very commonly
requested because a lot of men are not
given that by their primary partner or
maybe their private partner just doesn't
enjoy that for whatever reason but I
don't know if that's accurate since I'm
not a sex worker myself so what are some
of the most frequently requested
activities or act I think I think this
one may be more specific to me than
necessarily the experience of other
ladies but very frequently I have men
coming to me that want to have sex while
standing up because I'm so petite I only
weigh 85 pounds you can literally pick
me up and have sex while standing in a
variety of different positions I also
happen to be extremely flexible so I get
a lot of requests for a comment or
positions or perhaps some
creative possessions where the man is
standing and the woman is in doggy
position at the end of the bed or
perhaps we're having sex
using a chair or in the case of someone
with disabilities perhaps we're having
sex using their wheelchair as sex
furniture all of those things often are
requested
oral sex also huge huge requests it
feels great a lot of guys enjoy that
sensation because like you had mentioned
earlier it truly is a rarity and for
them it's a treat as far as specific sex
position goes women you have got to
start writing your men they really like
it when a girl is on top and is willing
to take control oftentimes in modern
society we still see this paradigm of
men on top woman below this standard
missionary position being the one and
only position that men are getting to
experience with any sort of frequency so
a variety of positions are often
requested from cowgirl to reverse
cowgirl doggy style and everything in
between you mentioned I'm sure we'll
come back to a lot of different details
but you mentioned in passing sex
surrogacy and I was hoping you could
just take a minute and define what that
is oh absolutely sex surrogacy is kind
of an interesting thing because the
definition tends to be personal with
that being said a universal way of
looking at sex surrogacy in the most
simplest of forms is that rather than
entering a traditional relationship with
say a the average woman that you would
meet at a bar you are instead choosing
to enter into a longer based
relationship in this case with a sex
worker in kind of replacing the
traditional girlfriend or wife with
courtesan escort companion you're
filling that role with something other
than what is the societal norm it's very
interesting though because when you
think about it didn't the King of
England have multiple ladies-in-waiting
didn't he have mold
to pull women that he was having affairs
with and having sex with and that's
really true for a lot of history when
you look back that having this secondary
person or oftentimes in the case of sex
surrogacy this primary person being the
person who's taking care of your sexual
needs and desires
it certainly deviates from what we would
expect out of society and now does this
combine then in some cases or is it
separate from because this is this is
something else that I wrote down
consensual non-monogamy which it seems
like you're an advocate for or at least
know quite a bit about are there
particular I know this is a blended
question but or do you have guidelines
for people who are interested in
exploring consensual non-monogamy
absolutely consensual non-monogamy first
off is defined as your partner knowingly
allowing you to go ahead and have sex
with another person in this particular
case with a sex worker this has a couple
of unique advantages over any other kind
of consensual non-monogamy because first
off you know that we're professional you
know that I'm not seeking to steal your
husband and try to marry him that could
be the vs. thing from the case and
second oftentimes there's a medical
reason as to why people are interested
in consensual non-monogamy for example
the wife may have ovarian cancer and is
unable to have sex because of the simple
medical reason that it's it's not
feasible at that time she may go ahead
and acknowledge that her sexual needs
and wants and desires she's not able to
take care of those for her husband at
that time I'm a very firm believer that
sex is a need not just a want it's been
shown time and time again it has a
positive psychological effect on someone
and it absolutely has positive effects
in the overall experience of life so by
going ahead and allowing her significant
other to see the sex worker she is
acknowledging not just his sexual needs
but also doing so in the most ethical
way possible you're paying simply for a
service which I am simply providing I'm
taking care of the need that at that
particular time you're not able to
fulfill the wife has able to have a say
over that because it's consensual she's
able to dictate okay these are the
specific sex acts that I am comfortable
with or instead say I am comfortable
with everything but these particular
acts and then she's allowed to then
contribute her input so as far as
guidelines go for someone that was
interested in something like that we
have to go back to the same number when
I said earlier communication in the
willingness to have that communication
followed by number two consent if you
can get those two bullet points checked
often you're well on your way to going
ahead and entering this time of dynamics
mm-hmm
they you you mentioned before I
completely derailed the train of thought
one example of type of client and you
mentioned couples my understanding is
that you also have worked with a fair
number of adult virgins is that is that
accurate
can you explain just walk us through
with that experiences like I mean how do
you take someone presumably male
although that may not always be the case
and how do you make them comfortable how
do you walk them through that experience
the very very first thing and I keep
coming back to the same number one here
it seems to be very prevalent throughout
my work is the very first thing is that
communication aspect of getting to know
them as a human before getting to know
them as a sexual human I want to find
out what someone's hobbies and interests
are I'd love to see a photo of someone's
dog or hear about a funny story from
when they grew up that allows us to
connect first on that friend level where
we have that openness at that point I'm
able to then ask questions such as what
kind of sexual experience
have you had or what kind of sexual
experiences have you not had and many
times of virgins adult virgins have
never been on a date they've never had a
first kiss
they've oftentimes never proceeded past
first or second based so in their heads
they're really not just an adult virgin
but they're a virgin to the whole dating
experience in America unfortunately
society favors women when it comes to
sex and relationships where women are
sought after by men but men aren't often
times as sought-after by women therefore
we have a large sector of the population
which is male and also a virgin in their
20s 30s 40s and up they've simply either
never had the time to have the encounter
the opportunity has never presented
itself they've never specifically sought
out something like that or perhaps they
hire anxious perhaps they haven't had
the ability to do so because they feel
limited by a disability for example a
large number of the adult virgins I work
with full on the autism spectrum and for
me it's understanding who someone is as
a person and then understanding who they
want to be as a sexual person and kind
of developing our own customized date
experience that allows them to
experience the things that is that they
are missing so this this is fascinating
with someone who say has autism and
there's of course an entire spectrum
depending on the severity of symptoms or
the or the the way it's been diagnosed
and so on
but that would seem to also challenge
maybe in some ways the tool that you
keep referring to which is communication
and asking the right questions and so on
so what are some of the things you've
learned after you've say heard a story
or two looked at a photo of a dog had a
little bit of time to get the get to
know them as a person now it's time to
progress to maybe phase two where you're
starting to get to get to not only know
them but explore them as a physical
human being a sexual human being
what are some of the things that you do
to facilitate that I like to communicate
on several different levels
communication isn't just verbal a lot of
our communication as humans comes from
that more subtle either facial features
body posturing how we lean in or lean
away from something and so when I'm
working with somebody physically
hands-on I'm also trying to read some of
their body language and look for the
social cues that someone is calming down
and their respiratory rate is relaxed or
instead they're leaning into an embrace
rather than hesitant and pulling away
and perhaps more nervous for me I never
proceed to the next step or the next
level of intimacy until we have reached
that comfort barrier and then we're both
ready to progress forward a number of my
clients are war vets and they left for
the military and completely lost the
ability to have that normal first
relationship now that they're getting to
explore it for the first time they're
dealing with a number of different
things some of which have PTSD some of
which have hearing loss from explosives
and so I have to be willing to
communicate on whatever language basis
either verbally or non-verbally that
they're communicating in so I have to
have a certain level of flexibility when
working with adult virgins because you
really want to cater that experience and
really create something that's going to
be special memorable and personable
because this is a unique experience
for them there will never be another
first other than this one thing so the
way I look at it I want to make that
first time be everything they ever
dreamed hoped and desired I'd like to
get into some specifics related to that
so I remember when I lost my virginity
and as I suppose fortunate to be pretty
young at the time but I was a nervous
wreck I mean I think that many guys are
so let's say that you're you're sitting
down with someone who's very
understandably nervous on on
or many different levels what are some
of the specific things that you've done
or questions you've asked or things that
you've said to make them less nervous to
make them more comfortable I know it
depends on the person but what are some
specific examples that you can give of
anything that that you've done across
clients to help them to melt into the
moment so that they can be less
preoccupied and nervous absolutely I
think that happens on multiple different
levels the first thing I do is I like to
create a certain ambiance in my room
when we walk in I like to create a
visual change by going ahead and
lowering delights and I put on the
little bit of relaxing background music
this way the rest of the world and the
rest of the brothel and the rest of
everything has the opportunity to kind
of melt away for a moment it's creating
a space specifically for this encounter
and kind of setting the stage that helps
with that first step of visual
relaxation do you have any favorite go
to background music do you have any
particular background music so you like
I love Enya huge fan of Enya it's soft
its melodic its relaxing it's very easy
to take that to a romantic place and
it's not so dominating lyrically that it
would inhibit conversation and
communication it just flows very calmly
and naturally in the background another
one I really enjoy is Lindsey Stirling's
violin pieces those can be a lot of fun
if you want something a little bit more
upbeat and energetic that's a lot of fun
to listen to
and then the genre of chillstep
is the third music choice I tend to go
to tends to have a little bit of more of
the beating of rhythm to it and kind of
help set more of that sexual tempo love
it alright very helpful okay please
continue so you've set the the room tone
so to speak what's what what then well
go ahead and assume that the person I'm
working with here is a neurotypical male
virgin who has never even so much as
kissed a woman before and this is
something I see
almost every single week so the very
first thing that we need to do is
establish a physical physical connection
this starts oftentimes with hand-holding
and interlacing of the fingers playing
with the fingertips and encouraging them
to reciprocate that same motion touching
my fingertips stroking my hand from
there that progresses to perhaps gentle
kisses across the neck and shoulder
region something that is a little bit
less intimate than lips on lips contact
for that first time kind of allowing
someone to experience what that
sensation is like because just just stop
for a moment and imagine that you've
never kissed a woman before you have no
idea what that sensation is going to be
like on your lips is there a taste to
the skin how does the smell of her
perfume
or the shampoo she used affect your
experience by slowing things down and
really really exploring that first few
steps of intimacy it allows you to
explore the depth of it and really
appreciate that act for what it is
foreplay going ahead and just having
very very non traditional for place such
as gentle shoulder rubbing using my
fingers to run them through someone's
hair or tracing my fingertip over the
outer edge of their ear maybe running my
fingers along their lower edge of their
jaw those little acts of touching
connection communicates non-verbally
that one it's okay to touch me too
and two this is going to be a relaxing
experience I'm not going to try to
undress someone have them on the bed on
their back and try to hop on top of them
and ride them till they orgasm that's
not good that would be the exact
opposite of the kind of experience I
want to create for my male virgins I
want them to really appreciate that
sexual connection another thing that's
worth mentioning here too and this is a
very interesting thing that more
frequently than not male virgins are not
able to reach orgasm during their first
sexual experience because of the nerves
and anxiety it often does affect
performance and that is a very norm
biological occurrence it's not something
to be ashamed other feel as if that
ruins your experience so I also like to
set up the intention that the goal is to
explore each other sexually and if we
manage to achieve orgasm during that
process all the better but I don't like
to place an emphasis on we're going
until you orgasm because sex is so much
more than the Big Finish sex is a
journey it's an adventure it's not just
sex penis and vagina it's it's so much
more than that and so I'd say over all
from my virgins to make them feel
comfortable is I let them know that it's
not just sex
it's the touches it's the kisses it's
their first kiss when I'm looking them
directly in the eye and I'm reaching my
hand behind them and lowering their head
towards mind and giving them that
self-confidence to reach out and lean
forward and kiss me that that's an
incredibly powerful thing and it's an
amazing gift to be able to give another
human being
definitely you know I think these
examples you've given have been very
helpful in terms of clients demographics
and characteristics because many people
listening may have had before listening
to this a certain image in their head of
the client like who is the client who
comes to who goes to a brothel or works
with escorts for instance it's what I
mean who goes to the ranch or works with
sex workers if you had to broadly pain I
mean are there certain other certain
demographics or psychographics that are
particularly prevalent the easiest
picture that I can paint is somebody who
is over the legal age of consent and
with this I will mention too in that the
northern brothels you have to be 18
years of age in the southern brothels
which are near Vegas you do have to be
21 of age so do keep those things in
mind you have to meet the age
requirements to end
the brothel and that's it that that's
literally the only requirement to be
able to come to a brothel I see men I
see women I see individuals who are
intersex I have folks that are trans I
have folks that come to see me with no
interest in sex at all that are
completely asexual and instead they just
want have experiences and cuddle with me
I see couples and adult virgins I see
nonverbal individuals who have to
communicate using a tablet and I see
folks that are in their 70s who are
mourning the loss of their wife of 50
years
I see everything from adult virgins who
are 18 years in age to adult virgins who
are 50 years in age I see men who
haven't had sex in 25 years and I see
men who have sex on the frequent but
they have a very specific fetish that
they can't ask their general like their
general sex partner to fulfill for them
it is such an incredible rainbow of
people that come to see me for just a
huge huge variety of women and
unfortunately our society kind of has
this stigma in a way when we think of
hua brothel client is where we painted
this picture of this seedy guy and his
30s who isn't really well-kept and
probably has tattoos and piercings and
just as a disrespectful negative
character on society we have all these
negative connotations with sex work sex
work clients with the reality of sex
work is in this country that when you
take a step back and look at the reality
I see everybody from the mailman to
people who work in governmental office
the range is absolutely incredible
what are some other misconceptions about
sex work sex workers clients there of
any any other misconceptions in
particular that you'd that you'd like to
speak to or that kind of minds in
regards to the women themselves there's
this misconception about sex workers
that we
ended up here because of something that
rather than choosing we're reacting to
something that happened to us that could
not be further from the choose the
majority of women that come to work at
the brothels are incredibly
well-educated come from a variety of
different backgrounds all over the
country in a whole array of different
ages and body types like to give you an
idea one of my co-workers Emilia Hart is
just incredible she has multiple college
degrees she's a massage therapist and is
truly a brilliant mind meeting her for
the first time you wouldn't realize just
how well educated she is until you get
that opportunity to sit down with her
and you hear the quality of what she's
saying and you realize this is somebody
that could be pursuing a doctorate if
they so chose but instead they've chosen
to go ahead and embrace sex work and the
one commonality that I have found
between the women who choose to do sex
work and then furthermore choose to do
sex work on a long-term basis for me
that six months a year two years those
ladies all look as sex work as a form of
service to the community it's something
that we're able to do a genuine need
that society has and has always had that
we're fulfilling we're fulfilling a
service just like anybody else any other
legal profession we pay our taxes we
have to pass a stringent background
check in order to have a license to work
at the ranch we're required by law to go
ahead and be tested for sti's and STDs
every single week it's an incredibly
professional upscale environment with
incredibly high class women and I wish
that Mora society would understand that
sex is truly a societal need and so long
as that need exists sex work will always
be the natural answer well I think it's
just this is an important point because
in the u.s. at least and elsewhere
certainly I mean if you look at the war
on drugs which has been by almost any
measure and abysmal failure with all
sorts of perverse side-effects and costs
and ruin lives
associated if you if you take something
that is even more so an innate human not
just drive but need like sex and try to
in any way repress it or prevent it
completely which certainly happens in
many different areas of the US and
different cultures in the u.s. that it
will find some type of release valve
whether you want it to or not and that
the more proactive intelligent
benevolent way to approach that is to
create a structure within which you can
explore that or provide that safely with
proper regulation and taxes and so on
and so forth so I really think this is
an important point to underscore for
many reasons but the question I wanted
to ask you and maybe you can certainly
provide thoughts on some of the other
ladies but aside from the service
component and helping say these vets or
clients who really need this what else
do you get out of it like why do you why
do you do this and it's not a moral
judgment at all like I'm fascinated by
it clearly but like what do you what do
you personally get out of this that
makes you enjoy the work for me what I
get out of it is a very honest look at
humanity and a very honest connection
with other human beings in a deep and
meaningful way that society otherwise
could not provide for me I've always
long maintained that modern America is
trapped behind the cellphone behind the
computer screen where we no longer
interact with each other on that
face-to-face level we don't hug each
other we don't touch each other
and by virtue of my job I don't get to
just hug and touch the other human
beings in my world I get to interact
with them in incredibly deep meaningful
ways intimately intellectually and for
me it's stimulating and it's enriching
in my life I find that it gives my life
value and it gives my life purpose
there's so much to be learned by just
getting to sit down with another human
being let alone getting to enter the
bedroom with another human being it
allows me to learn more about myself at
the same time what have you learned
about yourself would you say over the
last two years I've learned that I am an
incredibly confident woman and that I
don't need to overcompensate for
anything growing up four foot eight and
being head and shoulders below my peers
I always felt this internal competitive
nature like I'm not good enough I have
to work a little bit harder I have to be
a little bit better I have to overcome
what to me felt like a handicap when
you're very petite people look down on
you they treat you like a young child
regardless of the fact that you're an
intelligent young woman they don't give
you that same level of respect and so
for me I learned to have that inner
confidence in myself and truly believe
it and know that my value and my worth
is very very tangible it's very very
real and it certainly isn't inhibited by
who I physically am if anything I've
come to find my height to be an
advantage in my business which is kind
of a great irony in a way yeah that's
coming full circle I was looking at this
description which is striking with
natural red hair elfin features and a
starting list startlingly petite four
foot eight frames I mean that sounds to
me like a very strong set of
differentiators keep you an idea like
during a lineup I literally will watch
the guys but they'll make eye contact
with each girls and they'll reach man
you just see their heads look all the
way down because they
to lower their head contact in
comparison woman standing on my left and
my right so it's very very fun you
always get to see this funny little head
nod when I'm in line up in it and it
makes me smile what what have you
learned about what have you learned
about men in the last doesn't have to be
two years but just in this work what are
what are there any particular insights
that you can share or things that you've
realized about men and I understand that
they're that men is a huge category and
that there are many many many many
different types of men with different
likes and dislikes and so on but if you
were trying to generalize are there any
other is there anything in particular
that you would say you've learned about
men I would say the biggest thing that
I've learned about men is that society
miss judges them and places this
expectation of toxic masculinity which
prevents men from embracing that
emotional in that sexual side of
themselves that's incredibly limiting a
society for us to have that kind of
moral judgment against 50% of the
general population that's that's
craziness we don't allow men to express
themselves sexually we don't allow men
to express themselves emotionally and
when somebody comes to see me at the
ranch all men regardless of what they
think that they are coming to the
brothel for the primary reason that they
are coming to the brothel is because
they want to be heard they want to be
listened to and most importantly they
just want to be understood
mm-hmm what is what is it is there a
particular ask or need or fantasy that
guys come to you with and they think
that it's somehow unique to them but in
fact you see it all the time is there
anything that that comes to mind that
would that would I suppose fit
fit those parameters I'd say there are
two things that I see that are most
unexpected the first we've kind of
already touched on which are adult male
virgins many adult male virgins come
with this fantasy of losing their
virginity and they don't realize that
it's such a common thing and they feel
very insecure and nervous about it when
it's actually a very common happening so
that would probably be the first thing
the second thing that I see very very
frequently is men simply want to have
sex with a woman when she has her eyes
open
a lot of women have this interesting
habit where we close our eyes when we're
having sex where we don't want to make
that direct eye contact with our partner
for a lot of men they find that to be
incredibly incredibly erotic and
stimulating to see all the little micro
muscles move in twitch is somebody gets
closer and closer to orgasm getting to
feel their breath and also see the
expression change in their eyes and in
their face and watch their pupils dilate
and contract and response to what you're
physically dealing I mean god it doesn't
get much hotter than that no yeah no it
doesn't there's a site that I wrote
about in my second book for our body
where there are actually two chapters
not just one two chapters dedicated a
female orgasm for those people
interested but there's a site I don't
even know if it's still around I think
it should be but it's called beautiful
agony and beautiful agony is is a site
dedicated to user submitted videos of
faces as each person is orgasming so
it's it's specifically focused on faces
during climax and orgasm so yes I agree
that's that's that makes perfect sense
to me so men who want to have sex with a
woman while she has her eyes open
incredible and it seems such like a
simple request to but honestly it can be
kind of difficult as woman because you
have to be really confident in yourself
sexually confident in what you're doing
a relaxed enough where you can make eye
contact and not feel forced or
uncomfortable
in order for like eye contact during sex
to actually come off in a way that's
erotic you'd be surprised is actually
more difficult than you would think well
just maintaining eye contact in general
I think in conversation for instance
particularly particularly when talking
is difficult for a lot of people and
like anything else you have to practice
it just requires mileage I mean you
really have to put in the repetitions
question for you I suppose that is is
somewhat related because you mentioned
the the GFE right the girlfriend
experience is the number one request the
requested service that you offer now I
find this kind of puzzling in a sense
and I'd love to hear your additional
thoughts and the reason I say it's
puzzling is that I know I mean among say
type-a successful males who have
traveled a lot around the world it's
it's at least in my experience I mean
the vast majority particularly overseas
but not necessarily limited to overseas
have had experiences with sex workers
very very very very common and for many
of them they choose to go to sex workers
because they don't want to contend with
the emotional elements of a relationship
or potential attachment or follow up
they have this sexual need and they view
visiting sex workers as a very sort of
clean and simple way to satisfy that so
so why is the girlfriend experience the
most requested I it's yeah yeah no it's
it's that's very that's unexpected for
me so maybe you can speak to that sure
and I'll even go ahead and speak it's
just a specific example you gave these
men that travel for work they choose
specifically and this is a conscious
decision to not engaged in a traditional
relationship oftentimes what they will
do is they'll see the same lady on a
frequent reoccurring base
rather than seeing different ladies so
in a way they're kind of entering a
unique committed sort of relationship
within that bounded time constraint that
they are they're together with that
person it allows them to be in control
of the duration of the intimacy how that
interaction goes and you don't have to
do any of that maintenance and upkeep as
a relationship does and then
economically speaking interestingly
enough it's cheaper to frequently visit
sex workers than actually have a wife
and get married oh that doesn't surprise
me I mean I I hear I remember somebody I
heard somebody say in a movie they said
free sex is the most expensive sectional
because if you have that need and you
need to get that need met going to the
legal brothel is an amazing solution one
you know you're not going to catch
anything because we're literally tested
every single week to you don't have to
worry about any of your private
information being violated
especially for professional men that may
not want to be open or put themselves at
risk of doing any illegal activity sex
in Nevada at the brothels is a hundred
percent legal you can go ahead and pay
for sex and you don't have to worry
about that legal risk of things so for a
lot of men that's a huge advantage too
and another thing that I often times see
with men that fall into that particular
situation is they enjoy the familiarity
of the same individual girl but they
know that they're not obligated to do
anything they don't have to text they
don't have to call they don't have to
say where are you why didn't you do the
laundry you don't get any of that
nagging or any of those negative
relation things that can be oftentimes
detrimental and said you kind of get to
cherry-pick the best parts of
relationship you get to go out on dates
and have dinner we can rent a helicopter
and fly over Lake Tahoe and take photos
together whatever this
scenario happens to be it gives you the
exact experience you want within the
constraints of time that you have
available to yourself without any sort
of commitment or obligation beyond that
so I was just gonna say you know the
most of what you just said would lead
the the friends I mentioned before to
nod their heads and say yes exactly so
the where do we then find the girlfriend
experience sort of falling in terms of
appeal because I'd love to hear your
thoughts on that and I should also say
for people listening I mean I think
there is I certainly find value in
relationships intimate relationships and
sex with with girlfriends that I'm in
deep committed relationships with
nonetheless I mean this this is I think
another piece potentially another piece
of the puzzle that's worth at the very
at a very minimum understanding so the
the GFE why is that why is that the most
requested right because I mean I guess
in my mind maybe I'm just a savage but
I'm thinking all right if I'm gonna pay
for four hours I've already established
that I'm attracted to you why not have
sex for four hours but please please
speak on the GFE why why is that the
most requested do you think of course I
think the first thing that needs to be
discussed is the girlfriend experience
is just that you are creating an
experience for somebody it's bounded by
the constraints of our time together
it's not a perpetual relationship which
is what makes it different than say a
standard girlfriend it's an experience
within that experience you're getting a
couple of very unique let's call them
features one of the features of the
girlfriend experience is that I
specifically take my time to get to know
who somebody is on an even greater level
because generally speaking within a GFE
experience
we visit each other more than just once
this isn't generally a stand-alone
encounter but rather a regular
occurrence a couple times a year if
somebody lives locally perhaps more
frequently whatever it's so maybe I
dress a little bit here but it's kind of
important to point out that one of the
classic futures of girlfriend experience
is that more frequently than not it
tends to be a reoccurring experience and
it also allows us to develop a
relationship with each other for men
emotion and sex very very frequently go
hand in hand it's not just a pure
physical arousal but it's also that
mental stimulus it's being able to sit
and have a quality conversation with the
woman you're about to have sex with like
I think that's incredibly appealing to
sit down with somebody and have them
perhaps talk about astrophysics with me
before foreplay oh yeah bring it on that
is foreplay for my brain right there
and what is the what is the average
duration of a girlfriend experience
session so to speak I'd say on average
between the 2 to 4 hour range of course
I've had experiences more limited debt
and then I've had experiences more
extend you 'san that to what I know this
is going to seem like a left turn but
we're gonna jump all over the place what
do you what are your feelings or
opinions of porn as a sex worker ooh
that's a very interesting question
indeed I think that porn is ruining
America it's ruining relationships and
it's ruining intimacy what porn does is
it creates this almost addictive
compulsion where you're scrolling
through you're watching the porn we're
gonna assume it's a male watching at
this point he's masturbating he's being
very very rough with his genitalia and
he is just going at it for however long
it so may be first
other than investing his time and energy
in a genuine connection with the real
human being he's watching the Broadway
equivalent of a sex act that is being
overdramatized for his entertainment so
I'll tell you right now that everything
that women do in porn is the exact
opposite of what happens in real life
secondly it's causing men to cause
physical harm to themselves they are
masturbating so roughly that often times
they lose sensitivity and it makes it
difficult for them to orgasm and climax
with their partner which of course leads
to the almost a cycle of going back and
masturbating because they're not able to
orgasm with their significant other they
have to have that rough stimulus the
third thing that it does is it
perpetuates this culture where we look
as sex and we look at women as objects
there's no real way to verify
unfortunately that all of the porn that
you're coming across on these websites
is consensual porn you have no idea how
old these women necessarily are you have
no well if they've been compensated for
their time like unless you've really
done your research and you've picked an
ethical porn website that does perfect
record-keeping based in the United
States there's no guarantee and the
majority of guys that I know they just
go to some website they just scroll
through and they click on the first
thing that looks interesting without a
second thought as to what the impact is
on the lives of the women and what kind
of a societal norm that perpetuates if
we manage to remove porn from our
society I think you would see men
spending more time developing genuine
connections with other women they would
be going out more they would be
exploring those dynamics and exploring
those things rather than that self
gratifying behavior which is also
physically damaging probably also be
good for business at the bunnyranch I
would imagine overnight I suspect that
you guys would be overrun
but what pandemonium and the very first
thing that I would have to do believe it
or not is invest in a ton
flesh lights my friend used to my friend
used to sell this he's he was he was the
man behind the flashlight so maybe you
can describe for people why you why what
the flashlight is and why you'd be
investing in the flashlight it is an
apparatus used for male sexual
gratification that is in a tube that
looks very much so like a flashlight but
rather than having the inner working
light component instead it has an
artificial vagina or lips or derriere or
breasts made out of silicone or other
flesh like feeling material which you
then insert your penis into for
self-gratification got it really
technical way to describe was tactical
see you would keep you to see you would
keep the fast running porn deprived
maniacs at bay by sort of hurling
flashlights at them over some type of
barricade like hand grenades just to
make sure that that you can keep this
tsunami of sexual agitation at bay now
that makes sense I like that yeah well
you'd have to take all these guys you
spent too much time on laptops and train
them on how to catch things because you
might just end up taking eyes out with
yes guys are hurting themselves when
they're masturbating they're gripping
too tightly they're pulling too hard
when you're using the flashlight it
takes away that ability it completely
takes it out of the equation so you're
still able to get sexual gratification
with yourself but you're also not
hurting yourself in damaging your
ability to enjoy sex with a partner so
honestly I think all guys out there the
number one things that they could do for
their own sexual wellness is buy a
flashlight this episode of the Tim
Farriss show is brought to you by the
flashlight okay that one was free that
fleshlight please donate many thousands
of dollars to your favorite benevolent
cause
donorschoose.org I'm sure will accept
your money but you're welcome it's not a
replacement for a real human being it
certainly isn't a replacement for the
true flesh-and-blood thing but it
certainly is an alternative option for
single men out there who are
masturbating at home and are starting to
experience some of these sensitivity
issues it's something to bear in mind
because it's gonna make her sexual
experiences so much more intense and so
much better yes for the Fuji for the
real vagina deficient masses out there
who are masturbating themselves into
genital destruction words to the wise
all right so let me let me segue on that
to googling your name all right so you
have reviews online and I've seen you
described in very laudable terms so in
one word for instance this is one
reviewer in one word Wow in two words
[ __ ] yeah in a sentence drop your pants
ladies and gentlemen and see her now
okay so you you have you have as it were
very good yelp reviews like if you're a
restaurant I'd be like damn I need to go
to that restaurant so what separates a
let's just focus on female sex workers
what separates a good female sex worker
from a great female sex worker right
because you're sort of the the Michael
Jordan of your sport so and and you're
allowed to say communication but it
can't be your full answer and if you say
communication you can but you have to
give me very specific examples of what
makes you different okay but I think the
big differentiating factor is passion
that zest for life that inquisitive
nature and desire for more that lust
overall for life not just necessarily
for sex or money but rather that
constant desire and drive for what's
next what's more I'm passionate and I
want to learn and I want to explore and
experience so I'd say being passion
about what I do really is what separates
me and kind of puts me that head and
shoulders above everybody else I'm an
incredibly vocal advocate for sex
workers sex workers rights I'm an
incredibly well educated individual when
it comes to sex sex needs sex intimacy
and it's something that I really
consider myself to be not just an expert
in but something that I'm truly and
genuinely passionate about it has such a
great meaning and impact on my life
personally that it definitely has left
its thumbprint on the essence of Who I
am because I've allowed it to affect me
on that deep personal level I'm also
able to give of myself in a very deep
personal way that I think it's kind of
rare in our society these days so give
give me an example if you can because
not to not to really beat the Michael
Jordan and analogy to death but it's
like all right Michael Jordan clearly
had actually I heard an anecdote from
one of the mental performance coaches
for the Bulls at the time who I think
previously had worked the Lakers on
meditative and mindfulness practices who
said that you know Jordan was perhaps
the the only player who reflected the
skills he was trying to impart to the
others okay but he beat you so you have
say his ability to generate this being
in the zone at will or something like
that but then you have you have Jordan
as a brilliant technician tactician and
so on so the I will I'm interested in
digging into the passion but I need some
examples like how does that translate to
an experience for someone the best way
to verbalize that I would say the
easiest way to kind of encapsulate what
you're talking about
is to go back and reference something
that I'm very interested in which is the
48 laws of power
really phenomenal book really really
interesting Robert Reaves yes speaks
quite a lot about the mental capacities
of somebody how we view and interact
with the world around us there's a
certain level of a mindfulness that that
book preaches to be cognizant of your
decisions where you're making your
decisions rather than letting yourself
react to what's happening around you so
I guess one of the things that also
makes me different is that level of
mindfulness I always take that extra
step I always do just a little bit more
than everybody else would if it's
somebody's birthday and they told me
that in passing they enjoy chocolate
cake well I'm gonna go ahead and I'm
going to bake them a chocolate cake and
then I'm also going to go ahead and get
candles for it and then I'm also going
to reference back and find out what sort
of interest in hobbies they have in get
them a birthday present and a birthday
card I always like to take things to
that next level that next intensity
whether it be from simply doing say my
website and just blogging casually oh no
I'm very very careful and very specific
in the way that I blog I try to
communicate my point in my viewpoint
within my words I've really tried to
emphasize my beliefs and place an
importance on that connectivity and that
interaction that we get to share it's it
really is the encapsulating part of the
experience for me is being willing to
take the time and the effort to do a
little bit more than most when most
people would stop working that's where I
keep going I pushed just a little bit
harder whether that be through marketing
whether that be through client
interaction whether that be through how
I choose to present myself online all of
those things is just a little bit more a
little bit extra just really
demonstrating that I want to be known
for this field I want to be known for
creating these incredible lakes
is for people and I want people to have
those encounters and have those
experiences and think about them as a
potential for their own life so all
right let's talk about then something
you mentioned is on the bucket list for
a lot of men and that is a threesome so
if you are working with say one of your
female friends and who is also a sex
worker and providing that experience for
men what are some of the ways that you
guys would go above and beyond in that
experience and and specifically like I'm
curious about maybe some of the
technical stuff some of the acts
themselves things that may not be
obvious or things that may be unexpected
anything really that that is that
unfolds what are some of the what's the
secret sauce what are some of the magic
ingredients when it comes to a threesome
encounter the ultimate frosting cherry
on top whipped cream
dessert of it all is honestly a to girl
[ __ ] where the two of us are kneeling
before a guy who was standing one
positioned on either side of his member
both of our mouths and our hands on his
body looking up at him and pleasuring
him where he truly is the center of our
world for that moment I have had guys
rant and rave about that kind of
experience more so than anything else
when it comes to a threesome because
just being able to feel like wow I am
the center of someone's sexual attention
in the center of someone's sexual
universe is hot oh sure yeah no that's
I'm I'm not confused or surprised the
the related question I suppose for
people out there who are interested in
becoming better at giving [ __ ] right
what recommendations would you have for
them and their any dues or do nots
common mistakes
anything that you can suggest to enhance
the experience what are your thoughts if
you were teaching a class maybe you have
taught a class on this for them all
right so what are what are some of the
what are some of the key teachings the
first thing you need to do is look at
what your general [ __ ] routine is are
you doing the same things over and over
again are you focusing on the head or a
particular part of the penis are you
making eye contact what are you doing
right now
whatever it is that you're doing right
now the next step is to go ahead and add
to it so if you're just a standard job
focusing on that pause for a moment look
up and make really direct eye contact
with your partner and then keep going
while keeping that eye contact
maintained it's gonna change the energy
and change the interaction then you can
take it the next step further and start
playing with perhaps food have you ever
taken whipped cream and put whipped
cream on top of your man and then had
whipped cream off of his member that can
be an incredibly erotic way to do things
not to mention the fact that in a
technical term by placing a food object
it kind of gives your mouth a taste
guide for what parts of the body you
have and have not paid attention to yet
it really creates this moment where you
have to slow down and you have to make
sure you clean up all the whipped cream
and it's a really pleasurable way to
slow things down and enjoy the moment
and enjoy the action so it's about being
willing to try new things in your
[ __ ] and of course ladies watch the
teeth yes watch the teeth and be a good
bumper sticker so the good message to
impart hand no hand if hand involved
just say fingers full hand I mean I
guess you're 4-foot days or maybe you've
probably have tiny hands so I'm not sure
must make must must make guys feel
amazing they're like oh my god is my
[ __ ] really huge or her hands just
really small I don't care it's so
amazing
oh yeah so yeah so what are your
thoughts on hands cup them massage them
between my hands not too roughly you
really don't want to pull on them or put
serious pressure on them but just having
that added sensation there for a lot of
guys can actually make their orgasm
significantly more intense wait now when
you say you're talking about like one
hand is cupping like you're holding a
baby bird or something like that yes
kind of as if you had two eggs sitting
in the center of your hand and then
you're kind of spinning those two eggs
back and forth against each other kind
of sliding them against each other
sliding them against her hand kind of
providing a light tactile stimulation
got it and then what are you doing with
the other hand what might you be enjoy
the sensation of feeling deep inside a
woman and how they tend to perceive this
and a lot of guys who discipline to see
when they're masturbating whatever hand
they're not using they're placing on the
crook of their inner thigh and they're
placing pressure there but that tries
for the body is it transmits and
translates to the nerves that makes them
feel as if they are deep inside of a
woman's body so sometimes what I'll do
is I'll place my other hand that isn't
on their balls I'll place it against
their body against their shaft at the
very very base of it and kind of give
that pressure sensation as if they are
deep inside of a woman that combined
with the pleasure
I'm giving using my mouth and the
pleasure I'm giving using my hand it can
really create a mind-blowing orgasm
mm-hmm thank you thank you like if a guy
normally doesn't finish during a [ __ ]
a lot of guys find that they're not able
to by adding those two simple things it
can completely change their mindset on
blow jobs and make it one of their
favorite ways to finish
what is alright so we're talking was
mentioning a five-star yelp reviews
earlier so in the context of a threesome
that you're in charge of right you and
another woman are kind of running the
show so you already talked about man
standing two women on the floor
if you're looking at greatest hits like
what gets the most rave reviews for
finishing what is the last what is the
last five minutes look like the big ko
so the big ko often looks like the guy
on his back myself on top in doggy style
the other lady is reversed where she's
facing me but sitting on top of his face
in such a way that he's still able to
see and her and I are making out playing
with these chowder's breasts and really
getting into the encounter I happen to
be bisexual so I'm already head over
heels about everything that's happening
and most of the ladies that I do - girl
experiences with are also bisexual so
there's that energy of natural chemistry
between the two of us and that
attraction in addition to the focus on
his pleasure he is just so stimulating
both visually and then just in regards
to how he's feeling that a lot of guys
come that way and they come really
really hard a lot of fun because if you
have never gotten to have sex like that
you are missing out that is one of
life's like life's eighth wonder is a
mind-blowing threesome
oh no no disagreement there agreed
agreed
yeah that that's it's unfortunate there
aren't more threesomes in the world for
sure the big chaos
now just to really hone in on the visual
so you are you are on top of the man
mounted on the man facing towards his
head you'd mentioned doggy style but
you're kind of in cowgirl not really
cowgirl I guess it's cowgirl only when
you have your knees up but your knees
are down so it's still considered to be
cowgirl it's where I'm on top of him and
my body is upright rather than leaned or
tipped forward the other lady is facing
me parallel so at we're looking at each
other so she's facing him and she's
sitting on his face in such a way that
he's able to give her oral stimulation
but then he's also able to see
everything that's going
oftentimes we'll use mirrors for this if
the angle is a little bit difficult a
lot of our rooms already have them
installed to kind of give that visual
emphasis to not just the physical sounds
lovely all right I'm gonna before I just
get lost in reverie back to my
interviewing I want to talk about the
negotiating again because I'm I'm very
interested in this and I know we touched
on it very briefly but what types of
points are you negotiating are you
negotiating price or you know she like I
loved it for you to dig into the
specifics like give some examples like
what kind of stuff is being agreed upon
and settled on in that in that
conversation beforehand during the
negotiation the very first thing that is
discussed is what we are doing where we
are doing it what they desire to get out
of that experience and what kind of a
budget they are working with and at that
point yes we are definitely negotiating
over price of course the more flexible
someone's budget is the more in depth of
an experience are able to have there
definitely is a correlation there
between those two things what's very
interesting in our industry is that
there is nowhere else that we can talk
about price except at the physical
location of the brothel in our bedrooms
so this isn't something that can be done
in advanced online or over phone this is
something that you actually have to do
in person due to how Nevada law is
written there's no rates posted online
on my web site
none of that information is anything we
discuss so price is definitely one of
the things that we negotiate for it's of
course it varies from person to person
and it's worth mentioning that the ranch
is billed very discreetly so you can
feel comfortable using your debit or
credit card there because it is a
professional business and don't worry
about that being a concern it's a tax
consultation
what is the descriptor what shows up on
the statement I'm so curious
oh we actually
usually don't publicize that info okay
all right that's fine I would make
thousands of enemies sorry sorry I
didn't I didn't really think that one
through all the like wives listening for
all the things that might show up okay
got it got it all right so Safeway
potato chips ranch I think that's that
would be my code oh my god I just said
that out loud okay so all right let's
let's keep very discreet definitely
discuss price some clients are very
comfortable talking about
the intimate details of the sexual
experience they want if a client is
interested in roleplay they may be very
specific and say I want you to wear a
red schoolgirl skirt with a white tight
blouse top with your hair and high
pigtails it could be that specific or is
generic as I want to have sex if they're
a male virgin and they're not
comfortable talking about sex at that
point and so each person's negotiation
is to go a little bit differently but
generally speaking I like to cover the
where we want to go what we want to do
do they have a specific end goal in mind
or something that they really want to
experience and then I kind of custom
tailor and explain to them well based
off of what you've told me I think the
best encounter for you is going to look
like this generally speaking will want
to spend you know an afternoon together
and this is kind of what we're looking
at but price-wise and then we just kind
of take it from there either they're
able to do that and we're good to go and
this is where it's a negotiation because
we can go oh I can't quite get there
what if we take this activity away can
we still have plenty of time for
everything else what if what if I don't
get the power windows and I don't need
the fancy rims then where do we end up
what is the range if you're if you're
able to say I mean on kind of low end if
we're going a lean machine up to
like the works what's like the full
Cadillac I mean is there is it possible
to give a range on something like that
sure thing of course it's gonna vary
from lady to lady because we're all
independent contractors but a very very
general range or a way to frame work it
would be a very brief encounter could be
in the three figure brain range
something a little bit more in-depth
like going out to dinner would be
somewhere in the four figure range and
if somebody choose to suspend a night or
multiple deuce with me then we could
certainly approach that I figure range
there's been gentlemen who have stayed
at the ranch who have even spent in the
six to seven figures because that just
happens to be what their working budget
is because we see such a wide variety of
clients someone's disposable income is
completely varied somebody may be coming
in and wanting to spend an entire week
with a lady versus somebody coming and
that really is just looking to have a
really amazing massage and happy ending
there absolutely is no wrong request and
there certainly isn't a right request
it's whatever works for you for your
budget and just being willing to have a
conversation about hey you know this is
what I kind of had in mind this is what
I'm interested in what can we make
happen if someone comes into my room
with that attitude I have no doubt we'll
be able to make something work so I'm
just listening to some of these numbers
on the high-end debt is Dennis HOF still
the proprietor is he still the owner or
is it somebody else yes yes okay so
Dennis as my as I understand it was a
frequent customer who purchased the
business in 1993 for $700,000 and he
invested I think another half million in
upgrades and improvements so that means
and I don't know what the split is
between the ladies in the house so we
can get into that or not get into that
but it would seem like with one high
roller comes in he could have recouped
his entire investment or at least the
two tranches that I mentioned in the
business that's pretty amazing I mean if
that is actually the case I have no idea
how the economics work but it seems like
it seems like a very self-sustaining
attractive economic model I guess I mean
particularly if you have some of these
folks flying in from God knows where and
they're dropping six or seven figures I
mean that's gotta cover a lot of
incidentals oh it absolutely does that
dennis is gone and he has expanded
beyond just the bunny ranch as of this
moment he owns seven different brothels
we have up in the northern half of the
state we have the Moonlite bunnyranch
the love ranch North the Kit Kat ranch
and the sagebrush ranch down south near
Vegas we have the alien cathouse and
love ranch south so just to give you an
idea this is somebody that definitely
found his industry embraced it ran with
it and has created a tremendous
opportunity for the women that work at
these locations to kind of build their
own business within a business and a
brand within a brand so net you
mentioned like alien what was it alien
cat ranch and alien cat oh I'm so close
yeah cat house sounds a lot better than
cat ranch and are these are these
different genres are they different
types of food so to speak is kind of
like all if you want Italian go here if
you want Thai food go here if you want
this go there or is each or each of
those sort of buffet
choose-your-own-adventure
there there's everything here or do each
of them have a particular kind of
personality and style I think that each
location definitely has a unique energy
to that location
however it's not like all blondes go to
the bunny ranch in all brunettes go to
love ranch at each location you're gonna
find a variety of women in all ages
shapes and sizes and so really there's
not a wrong place to go as far as
facilities go we're able to travel
between the different ranches so if
somebody at kitkat ranches say
interested in having a threesome with
myself and Kenna Fox who works over at
the Kit Kat ranch Hannah would be able
to come up to the bunny ranch in and
join myself in a client or in Reverse
I'd be able to travel to the Kit Kat
ranch
and join her in her client they're all
within about three minutes of each other
so this is very very the northern houses
which is really fun because when you
think about it it literally is a buffet
there's 151 flavors and inevitably
there's going to be somebody that is the
perfect match for you so I have I have
friends who are say travel writers and
this is going somewhere and they find it
difficult to travel for pleasure because
as soon as they start traveling their
mind clicks into work mode and they
think about the story they could tell
the detail they could write down and so
on I suppose what I'm wondering is after
exploring this and pursuing it and
dedicating yourself to this as a
profession what are the things that
still turn you on the most like what are
the things that you're hoping we'll get
requested or does that make any sense
it's like a in a given week like God you
know it would really make my week if
somebody asked for this this or this is
there anything that would fall we would
come up in your mind I really like
working with gentlemen who are a little
bit older in age the reason for this is
that they already know how to treat a
lady right they're oftentimes very
familiar with sex and they're looking
for so much more than just that casual
quickie encounter they want to take
things to that next level of connection
and intimacy and I really find that my
guests who are in their 40s 50s 60s and
up they tend to have a certain maturity
that I find incredibly incredibly
attractive holy [ __ ] I just turned 40
I'm now an older gentleman oh wow I'm
not sure I guess sounds like a good
thing I guess it's being experienced
where at a certain point you develop an
appreciation for
women and I think for men that sometimes
can take a little bit longer and
sometimes doesn't quite click into place
until they reach a certain emotional
maturity where they're able to look at
woman is more than just a sex object but
as being these incredibly intelligent
and interesting beings a lot of guys
struggle to see women is more than just
sex objects for a number of years and so
sometimes it can take a little bit
longer for guys to reach that threshold
and honestly at that certain point too a
lot of those older gentlemen expressed
to me oh you know I just don't feel
comfortable having sex with people my
own age because I want somebody who's
younger I want somebody who's a little
bit more vivacious and energetic and
maybe they have a little bit of a harder
time finishing and so they're looking
for somebody who has the energy and
stamina to really work with them and try
exciting new things and I really enjoy
that interaction that and I'd say adult
virgins as well really really fulfilling
to me to spend time with those people
what what was the experience like
telling your family about your decision
to pursue this work can you what was
walk us through that conversation or
that day what did that look like oh
goodness
well I definitely could have done that a
lot better than I did I decided that
much like a band-aid I was just going to
pull it off and just be like I am a sex
worker I am going to work at the
Moonlite bunnyranch and no you cannot
change my mind and I pretty much said it
about that directly and just very
confidently said this is where I want to
go and this is the next step for me and
if you want to judge me for that you can
go ahead but you're not going to change
my mind I had already made up my mind at
that point and nothing under the Sun was
going to change it what would you what
were you doing at the time not to
interrupt but like what did your parents
think you were doing at the time before
that announcement well at that moment I
was actually working as a massage
therapist
and I was getting ready to move out of
the state for a couple of weeks just to
try the job and make sure I liked it and
so the first piece of news was I was
leaving for two weeks and here is why
and I decided in all of my stubborn
wisdom that I was going to inform them
of this the day before I was scheduled
to travel out to Nevada for the first
time we should have gone ahead and given
them a little bit more notice but at the
same time though I was going into it
with almost this armament around myself
for I'm expecting to overcome objections
and I'm expecting to have to explain and
go into like this whole presentation
about what sex in Nevada is and the
response I got back was pretty much oh
ok sweetie if that's what you want to do
are you sure that's something you want
to do is it safe for you gonna be safe
you are okay you can go do that oh okay
then that was a much better reaction
than I expected did you call a family
meeting or what was the did you go out
to the Olive Garden I mean what was the
what was the setting for this right like
he he passed the breadsticks and oh by
the way I mean what yeah so what what
was the setting I mean how did you how
did you tee it up just at home we were
in the living room I have the younger
sibling who isn't of the legal age of
consent and so of course they're not
aware of what I do professionally so I
went ahead and specifically pulled my
mother aside and had that conversation
with her privately in the living room
and was she watching TV where you're
like hey let's just DVR what you're
watching or was she doing a crossword
puzzle I just like I'm trying to
visualize that scene at the time she was
just hanging out in the armchair reading
the magazine I sat down next to her and
said you know I want to tell you
something she put the magazine down and
I just kind of blurted it all out there
so I'm gonna be a legal sex worker and
I'm gonna go working about it and I just
a cascade of information kind of
tumbling out of my mouth as I'm trying
to explain things and my mom's face is
completely unfazed at this point which I
have to say bravo to her for that I
definitely didn't expect her to take the
news quite as well as she did and I was
very happily surprised that she was just
oh okay that's nice another crazy
adventure that you want to go on that's
about normal how how do you explain that
I mean did you just was your mom like a
freewheeling free-thinking hippie back
in the day or I mean having come from
Ireland I don't know the full background
is she from Ireland herself yes she is
extremely extremely on the more
conservative side of things which is one
of the reasons why I was expecting some
of the objections yeah coming to the
States
she's kind of adapted a little bit more
of the liberal stand points here in
Ireland especially in Northern Ireland
right now and especially back then when
we lived over there in the country there
was a very negative stigma attached to
sex work I'd kind of done the research
is what sex work is like in other
countries and other places and one of
the things I came across is information
about how sex work exists in Ireland
which it does not and I kind of again in
that way but I tend to overthink things
had this mental impression of what her
reaction would be and the way that she
looked at it she's like hey you know
what so long as you're not racing those
damn horses anymore and falling off and
breaking your arm you're just gonna go
have sex in Nevada cool that's not bad
compared to some of the crazy things
that I have done with my life that's
pretty understanding when you think
about it from the sheer safety
standpoint being a jockey was certainly
a riskier profession than being a legal
sex worker in Nevada my job is actually
incredibly incredibly safe both because
of how the location is set up in
addition to the legality and laws that
protect the ladies
so let's let's shift gears a bit now
I'll ask just a handful of rapid-fire
questions that I asked just about
everybody and we'll just spend a few
minutes going through four or five of
these and then I'll let you get back to
your day this has been so much fun I
could go for hours and hours and hours
but I am enjoying this so much no this
is this is I'm really glad we were able
to connect and I will I will have
already thanked the person who made the
future introduction in the intro but
let's talk about books because you
collect books are there any books that
you have gifted the most to other people
are there are there any books that you
have given out more than once as gifts
that come to mind or that you would give
as gifts definitely I would say the top
three books that I tend to give his
gifts the first one would be a book
that's written by Dennis HOF called the
art of the tenth it literally talks
about his journey how we ended up
getting the bunnyranch and a lot of the
intimate details in relationship to sex
in Nevada for anybody that's interested
in what I do wanting to learn a little
bit more about the industry that is
always the first book I give is this is
kind of your handbook as it were to the
world of legal sex in Nevada the second
book that I give out most frequently is
to my co-workers it would be the 48 laws
of power a lot of the ladies haven't had
the opportunity or haven't been exposed
to that book and so I think that it's a
great tool to get into the hands of
women and get that positive thinking
going that energy that that book really
tends to encapsulate and the third book
is kind of an interesting one it's a
book called Memoirs of a Geisha
it speaks as to the life of a woman who
ended up being a Geisha in Japan during
the World War 2 era who was kind of
purchased from her family and on
willingly brought into this very foreign
world that could not be any more
different than what her life was like
the reason why I tend to recommend this
book for other people is that there's
this incredibly beautiful humanistic
element in the way that she describes
author uses language that is very very
rich and colorful and it sits you into
that time and place where you smell the
fish in front of you you hear the sound
of the shamisen that she's playing like
you can really immerse yourself into
that world and kind of get a sense of
what things were like at that time
mm-hmm yeah it's a fantastic book and
the author actually wrote the entire
book twice he wrote the he wrote it
first was dissatisfied with how it
turned out scrapped it and started over
and wrote it a second time which is just
speaking as the writers unimaginable
I've thrown out chapters but the entire
novel oh my god and yeah it's it's
really it also sheds light on some of
the craft and art form related to being
a courtesan during that period of time
and I actually had the opportunity to go
to to spend some time in I think it was
Kyoto in Japan I spent a lot of time in
Japan and to to arrange a formal dinner
with performances with a number of
friends of mine with to what they call
gaggle so instead of Geisha
it's a would call them gay : gaggle with
a KO at the end and the same idea a
different dialect different label
effectively no sex involved but came in
and played the shamisen and a did a
number of traditional dance routines and
prepared tea and went through all of
this rituals very beautiful experience
that that I highly recommend if people
have the opportunity so those those are
those that
diverse set of three books next question
is a purchase of less than $100 doesn't
have to be less than $100 that is most
improved your life in the last year or a
recent memory any any purchase that has
improved your quality of life that comes
to mind could be something that cost
five dollars it could be something
that's free actually or anything sort of
in that range that is a really
interesting question I would have to say
believe it or not and it seems like such
a strange little thing I like to cook
for myself a lot and I tend to eat very
clean and healthy I enjoy a lot of
vegetables the one contraption that I
find myself using time and time again is
one of those little spaghetti creations
where you insert the squash or zucchini
and you kind of twist it and it turns it
into a noodle instead it makes the
vegetable really easy to cook it's great
for a meal prep and given how hectic my
workweek is having that easy-to-use tool
available to me as I made my life a lot
easier so it's a it's a vegetable
spaghetti maker effectively so it'll
it'll it'll push it through some type of
press to slice it into these thin strips
is that what it does yes and then if I
had to go slightly above $100 I would
have to say that my cordless Hitachi has
been a gift from God okay the cordless
Hitachi Magic Wand which has which has
more settings has a lot more settings
and now you're not limited to just being
harnessed by this cord now you have a
lot more freedom of movement with the
toy and having that available within the
context of my job has been a ton of fun
we've had so many great experiences with
it it's been fantastic all right Hitachi
same thing I said to the fleshlight
first ones on me call me
your official sponsorship all right so
the Hitachi cordless if you were to be
given a billboard you could put anything
on the billboard and metaphorically
speaking to get a message out to
millions or billions of people so it
could be a few words could be a single
word could be a paragraph it could be
someone else's quote what would you put
on it or what might you put on it well
the first part of that would be as to
where and I think that I would go ahead
and choose to put mine as close to the
White House is physically possible where
people in legislature are going to have
eyes on this thing as frequently as
possible and my vest message would be
very very simple sex is a need not a
want sex legalization is the future of
America I like it sex is indeed not a
want legalization it's it's the next
logical step the fact that our country
has it in one single state and only
within the constraints of specific
locations within that Strait is of
course very limiting it means that
you're required to travel to Nevada in
order to legally spend time with a sex
worker in the United States and for a
lot of people that's not feasible and so
having legal options that are run very
similar to the Nevada brothel system but
in other locations I think is where our
country is going to inevitably be going
yeah it's ridiculous I mean I because if
we're viewing it through the lens of a
need of course sex workers are
everywhere and they just get pushed
underground where safety is compromised
and there's no oversight in the case
that it is maintained as illegal in
those locations so it's it's going to
exist whether regulators choose to
ignore it or systematize it and embrace
it in some capacity and they might as
well get the tax revenue and decrease
the risks for everyone involved so I
agree with it's often said that
prostitution is the oldest profession
and that really is true I mean if you
look back in
history and you go back into ancient
soon there and Mesopotamia and
Babylonian society you have this
incredible conceptualization of
something called sacred sexuality where
by doing sex work that's what brought
them closer to their deities at that
time that's what brought them closer to
the divine the sex workers or in this
case they were also priestesses of their
particular deity were incredibly revered
they lived in the temples themselves
they were treated like gold they were
incredibly well respected for the
service they provided to society when
you look back on how the kings of Europe
treated their their mistresses for
example oftentimes gifting them with
titles and nobility and land lavish
jewels sex workers have always been
treated as a treasure and it's only in
recent societal times that we've instead
taken this negative connotation and kind
of attached that on to sexcellent mm-hmm
yeah
ya know it's there's so many there's so
many changes needed in this country but
that's certainly one of them if you were
let's say you had a chance to educate a
class of young minds so you are given
the opportunity to teach a class
so say once per week seminar for a
semester for college freshmen or college
seniors it could be even high school
let's say a high school senior or
college freshman let's just say that
what would you teach and what would you
what would you focus on does not have to
be sex related but if you had to teach
something that you feel you know a lot
about that you'd be qualified to teach
on in some way what would you teach what
would the class be I think I would give
lectures about interpersonal
relationships and connectivity as it
relates to our society as a whole why we
should be more cognizant of how we treat
our service staff waitresses hotel
concierge things of
nature how we interact with humanity
around us as a whole how do we treat say
the McDonald's worker or the person
checking us out at Walmart how do we
interact with our classmates and our
colleagues what about the interpersonal
relationship between that
student-teacher dynamic I think I would
want to really go into talking about the
depth and meanings of those different
connections and how they can be used to
better and enrich our lives in society
if we're able to change that
generational mindset of the youth and
get them to put their cell phone down
and sit down and have a meal where
they're talking amongst their peers
that's going to generate new ideas
that's going to generate new innovations
that's what's going to take us to that
next point in our society where all of
these things we say we'd like to
accomplish within our society will
actually be achievable through that
unitive mind that cognitive collection
of everyone contributing and interacting
and working together and kind of forming
this unity in this bond and sure you
could say that it could be about sex but
really I think that it comes down to
that level of connectivity that level of
interpersonal relationship is vital to
humankind I agree so now we're at the
tail end of this conversation of this
round one at least and people can find
you online if they want to say hello at
Alice little on Twitter then you're on
the bunny ranch bunny ranch comment
forward slash Alice - little where else
could people find you online yep my
twitter is actually at Alice oh did I
leave off the last sorry about that
Alice little and I maintain my own
personal website and blog the Alice
little dot-com and you can go on there
to see photos of myself go through my
blog and see about the different topics
I write about the websites also designed
to kind of walk you through the
different experiences and encounters
that are available and of course any
questions related to sex work I'm open
to it's very important that we talk
about these things that it's very
important to embrace that curiosity so
if anyone wants to know anything about
what it is I do on the service I provide
I would love to get to know you and I'd
love to interact with you the best way
to do it which is Alice little at bunny
ranch calm Oh God
you just did it okay you may have to
modify your you know management approach
which is fine which is fine you will be
getting I don't think you'll have to
worry about getting too few email so all
right you may you may get the hug of
death this is one of those be careful
what you ask for things is there
anything else that you would like to
suggest to the people listening or to
recommend to them to ask of them is
there anything else you'd like to
communicate or in part before we wrap up
this conversation I would say it's an
overarching message if there was really
one thing that I had to ask of your
viewership it would be to have an honest
conversation about sex with someone it
doesn't have to be your significant
other it could be a friend it could be a
peer it could be a professor it could
even be me but let's talk about sex our
society as a whole isn't talking about
this and sex isn't going away it's a
natural and normal part of being an
adult in society and it's something that
we should feel more comfortable talking
about so go ahead and try to have that
conversation it might be a little bit
uncomfortable at first but I guarantee
if you push yourself and you actually
engage in that kind of interaction
you're gonna grow as a person for it and
really really benefit from it as a whole
good advice
very very good advice and you know
another tool in the toolkit that I'll
recommend for people is to check out a
book called and I think this
lies in many circumstances to things
that we are loath to talk about but
there's a book called radical acceptance
by Tara brach has also been on this
podcast that I think is a useful perhaps
a useful wedge for getting your foot in
the door to be open to accept certain
things about yourself and then then
discuss them alice's has been so much
fun thank you so much for taking the
time oh absolutely I had a blast thank
you so much for having me I really
appreciate it and everything that you do
thank you this is this has been I feel
like this conversation has been a long
time coming since 11-minutes found me 10
years ago and so much more food for
thought and I'm sure I'll have many many
more questions so perhaps we'll do
around to at some point but for yeah I'm
sure that there will be many follow-ups
and God save your inbox but and for
everybody listening as usual you can
find links to everything that we have
talked about including the books the
websites the Alice little calm at the
Alice little on Twitter and so on in the
show notes along with the show notes for
every other episode at teamed-up log
forward slash podcast and as always and
until next time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read
and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to four hour work week calm
that's 4-hour work week calm all the
spell out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
of this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I ended
up meeting with the CEO not very long
ago why are they so popular well they
are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people and you can send invoices track
your time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of entrepreneurs and
beyond you can take pictures and
receipts you can link your credit cards
and debit cards so all the things you
buy automatically appear in your fresh
books in the right category so on and so
forth makes taxes easy makes invoices
easy makes your life easier and also in
fact I recommend a PDF they didn't ask
me to read this part by the way they put
another PDF a while back called breaking
the time barrier subtitle how to unlock
your true earning potential so you can
search for breaking the time barrier a
lot of people ask me how can I get a
4-hour workweek with the service
business and the story in that ebook
it's PDF is the short answer it's really
really good so I think you should also
check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds
like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to FreshBooks comm /to tim and try it
out because it is a very good product
and i think you will find it simplifies
your life enjoy this episode is brought
to you by me undies I've spent the last
few years wearing underwear from these
guys 24/7 or close to it outside of
showers and sexy time in swimming and
they are the most comfortable and
colorful underwear I've ever owned you
should check out the camouflage boxer
briefs I'm a big fan me undies are
designed in LA and made from sustainably
sourced micro modown what's that it is a
fabric three times softer than cotton
trust me try it out you'll understand
why I wear these so much if underwear
isn't your thing though I would imagine
everyone wears underwear but if it isn't
your thing the undies also makes socks
their socks are spun from premium
material making them just as comfortable
as the underwear now right now the
undies has an exclusive offer just for
Tim Ferriss show listeners you can get
20% off your first order and free
shipping so check it out take a look
some of them are pretty rad they have
different cereals from your childhood on
underwear and a lot more me undies com
forward slash Tim take a look me undies
com forward slash Tim they offer a 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you're unhappy
with your purchase for any reason just
send it back and you receive a full
refund again that's me undies com / /
Tim for 20% off and free shipping
[Applause]